hey guys Pete peppers here and this is a
candy crush jelly saga level 163
walkthrough with some tips there are
some people in my group that are having
trouble with it so I thought I'd go and
play it again make a new video and add
some tips so one of the things that I
noticed when I play at the second time
it was that you know the it really comes
down to you know small board lots of
layers it's a tough level for sure so it
really comes down to making the best
choice of what you have available um you
know here is a perfect example in the
first move we could have made a striped
candy that would have spread you know by
moving the orange to the left there I
made a stripe gamma Chi made vertical
striped [ __ ] tomato you know those would
be the ones that would spread the jelly
and then you know there's also the rap
candy I think most people would probably
skip that because of the fact that it
doesn't spread the jelly but the better
move is to make this yellow match here
and go ahead and drop them one from the
top and we can make a color in candy
instead and then we have another choice
right away where we could make a fish
over here we can make a striped you know
we could just go ahead and spread this
jelly here spread that jelly there so
you don't want to think things out you
could also make a fish at the top what I
decided to do was go ahead and make the
fish to the left and then I can set up
this the striped over here by matching
the orange and that's actually giving me
a striped that I can combine with my
coloring candy so you know out there you
could have made the fish instead I don't
think the fish is is good because um you
know the stripes will pretty much
blanket a board like this since it's
small we didn't get the top rows but um
that's okay so now we have a way of a
pretty good
we have a pretty good start so let me
actually let that go for a second and so
if we count real quick we have one two
three four five six seven eight we have
eight squares that aren't covered yet
and three of them have blockers so you
know double fish will help us get
through that if we had you know in the
next 11 moves we had double fish three
times that would give us nine it would
take care of nine of those things for us
we're not going to get that opportunity
because pretty small but look you know
let's just think about what we're going
to do on each one obviously this be good
because it removes the blockers here we
can make a fish or we could make a raft
of the wrapped kind of goes down in
value once the once the blockers are
gone because the what's good about the
raft is making a strike + rap but we
don't really need that at this point you
know because fish are pretty much going
to kind of take care of things for us
here you know you can see we have a set
up or we could make a color bomb that's
never going to be a bad thing to do so i
went ahead and shot that downward same
thing here i can make the strike then
it's going to drop that red in the
middle down so just trying to work our
way down to making that got a little
unlucky there the you know the the one
on the end up move so here we have we
have the the stripe let's wrap combo
that's going to hit the one on the left
and it's going to hit the two at the
bottom I think the fish punched the
stripe would actually a little bit
better unless it goes exactly right here
it's actually going to cover more more
spaces but you know it's not real bad to
do this because you're going to hit the
fish anyways and it's going to go
somewhere so I could in retrospect I
kind of like the other move better but
um obviously in
and it's going to work out so you know
that is a thing to keep in mind too is
they you know when you make a fish
closer strike start me about a fish must
write with the rat puts a stripe that's
going to it's going to cause a lot of
things to fall in place and we had one
extra fish go so here you know we have
two moves we're going to make the fish
at the top because there's really
nothing else to make but we're going to
have to have it fall in a place where we
can match it and we get that and it will
come for our last square so that's that
so hopefully you get the idea you know
behind this take your time think about
all the different moves by doing that
even whenever I made one mistake there I
was still able to finish it off so if
you're having trouble definitely um you
know keep that in mind I hope this helps
please take a second to like the video
if you if you find it helpful lately
there's been some people that have been
going around and analyzed in my videos
with dislikes probably other channels
you know that I compete with so um you
know they get there getting a lot of
dislikes right away so hopefully if you
found it helpful you'll help me out and
give it a like definitely subscribe to
my channel because i'll be making more
videos like this real soon and good luck
with level 1 63